i'm dustin ingram developer advocate for
Google cloud platform today I'm going to
show you how you can run a wagtail
application on Google App Engine wagtail
is an open source content management
system built on django it's used by
thousands of organizations worldwide
with a strong community in fact wagtail
on App Engine is what powers the Google
Cloud blog at cloud google.com slash
blog
it also looks great is focused on user
experience and offers precise control
for both designers and developers app
engine makes it easy to deploy your
django app to the cloud and since
wagtail is built with django it's easy
to get up and running with wagtail as
well also similar to the Django project
wagtail recently announced it has
dropped support for Python 2 which makes
it a great fit for the Python 3 runtime
on the App Engine standard environment a
content management system consists
primarily of three parts an admin
interfaces for creating and updating
your content a database for storing your
content and a front-end for rendering
your content wagtail comes with its own
admin interface out of the box so the
first thing we need to do to get started
is create a new database for our project
wagtail works with a number of different
databases will choose Postgres on the
Google cloud platform console we'll go
to the cloud SQL instances page here
we'll create a new instance and select
Postgres 9.6 we'll just use a
development database for now but once
your app starts getting lots of traffic
you'll probably want to use a production
database instead next we'll specify an
instance ID
and default password
once the instances initialize we'll
select it
nice ready to go select the copy button
next to instance connection name and
hang on to this for later this string is
what we'll use to tell our app how to
connect to our database now
we'll go local being able to run your
app locally makes it easier to test
changes as you're working without
needing to redeploy every time in order
to run our waggles
we'll need a way to connect to the
database we've just created from our
local machine we could connect directly
to it but this will require that we
allow our database to accept incoming
connections directly from our local IP
address which would make it slightly
less secure instead we'll use a tool
called cloud SQL proxy this is a utility
that can run on our development machine
that creates a secure tunnel between our
machine and the cloud SQL database then
we could configure our app to talk to
this local proxy instead when running in
development mode installing the cloud
SQL proxy is easy see the link in the
video description for instructions for
your platform will start the cloud SQL
proxy with this command you'll use the
instance name you copied in the previous
step here we'll leave this running in a
separate terminal while we continue now
in a new terminal will install the
wagtail package locally I'm already in a
virtual environment that I created for
this project if you're not familiar with
virtual environments see the link in the
video description for guides for setting
up and activating a virtual environment
I highly recommend that any Python
project starts with its own virtual
environment installing the wagtail
package gives us the wagtail command
which we can use to generate a
cookie-cutter wagtail project we'll call
ours
my site so we'll use the command wagtail
start my site this will create a
directory called my site where our
wagtail app will live let's go into that
directory and see what our starter app
looks like there's a few things in here
that might look familiar most of the
core of our app lives in my site the
search and home directories are the sub
pages that we get by default we need to
update our wagtails app settings so that
it has the right information to interact
with our database the development
settings go in a file at my site slash
settings
Devki why we'll tell it how to interact
with our cloud SQL proxy which should
still be running by specifying localhost
as our host now we need to do the same
for our production settings
ideally any secret like a database
password would be encrypted with an
encryption key from cloud key management
service and held in cloud storage only
to be decrypted at runtime but we'll
just include our password in the source
code here to simplify things but be sure
to read the guide to secret management
in the video description similarly we'll
set a secret key which will be used for
cryptographic signing to secure our
tokens cookies etc by just assigning it
in a source however in production this
should be stored as a secret as well
we'll also need to tell our app which
host names is should respond to App
Engine gives you an appspot.com domain
by default so we'll use that here next
we're going to migrate our database and
start up our app locally since we opted
to use Postgres as our database we'll
need to add the psycho PG to python
package to the requirements text file at
the root of our projects my site
directory then let's install everything
we'll run the migrate command to get our
database initialized
finally we'll create an administrator
account that we'll use to log into our
wagtail app running Python managed PI
create super user will prompt us for our
username and password for our admin
wagtail user now we can run Python
manage PI run server to start the server
locally the wagtail app will be visible
on localhost at port 8000 by default
let's check it out in our browser by
visiting HTTP colon slash slash one
twenty seven point zero point zero point
1 colon 8000 once there we should see
this generic local message now that we
have the app configured let's deploy it
there's three things we need to do
before deploying first we need to
collect all our static assets like CSS
and JavaScript into a single directory
the collect static command will do this
for us next we need to create a main PI
file this is where App Engine looks for
an app variable which should be your
application wagtail puts this elsewhere
and calls it application instead so we
just need to connect the dots finally we
need to create an app gamma file to hold
our app engine configuration we'll tell
it to use the Python 3 runtime and we'll
set up handlers for our static assets
and for our other routes we'll also tell
it to use our production settings once
deployed when we're done our my site
directory should look something like
this now all we need to do is deploy
with g-cloud app deploy
once the deployment is finished we can
go visit our app at its URL on
appspot.com and we'll see that same
familiar welcome screen we can also sign
in with the super user account that we
created before
looking great we've got a content
management system now all that's left to
do is add the content which is easy with
wagtails web interface from here you
might also want to start working on your
apps front-end to create a more engaging
experience for your visitors or add some
models to begin defining your business
logic I've shown you how to set up a
cloud SQL database create a new wagtail
project and deploy it to App engines new
Python 3 runtime and I'm confident that
you'll be able to take this and build
something great on Google cloud the best
part about App Engine is that it grows
with your application when you aren't
getting traffic you don't pay anything
and as your app becomes more popular and
traffic increases it scales
automatically to meet that demand stay
tuned for the next episode where I'll
show you how to use stackdriver
to monitor your Python 3 app feel free
to ask questions in the comments below
and if you like this video please
subscribe to the Google cloud platform
channel for more videos like this thanks
for watching
[Music]